[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to if you
saw my review of the purge you know that
I thought it was vodka needing
improvement the movie nevertheless was a
huge surprise hit so much so that the
fourth movie is coming out this fourth
of July
despite the spin-off films rarely
reaching number one at the box office
and I'm just gonna take a walk yes and
say that's gonna happen again they're
still seen as successes in many respects
it's hard not to see why the purge is a
cool idea one night a year all crime is
legal and people take to the streets to
live out their darkest fantasies
everything from a satirical exploitive
and political level seems to easily
comment on itself there was just one
problem look for his film sucked added
it took place mostly in one home it was
filled with holes the characters were
weak and the whole angle of the film
seemed to be making the point that we're
all just one step away from making this
all happen it's kind that the people
horsing were one step away from
Handmaid's Tale happening I feel like
there's a few more steps I hammered in
how much the first film was well
hammered in coming across as pretentious
force tonight and much fun on an
exploitive level except for this guy who
played the leader he was so awesome I
gave him a name I called him Henry which
was technically the boyfriend's name but
he was so pointless I gave his name to
this guy confused don't beat the perch
just worked
and that was one of the biggest problems
with the film the economy is supposed to
be better people social statuses were
supposed to be better all because of
this one day because it works don't
believe me science we are inherently a
violent species the denial our true
selves is the problem the countrywide
catharsis creates psychological
stability by letting us release the
aggression we all have inside of us yeah
helping lying going national lampoon's
vacation again unless it got manure for
your brains next you'll be telling me in
my Fox kids were a few Tony J didn't
play the kingpin I really shouldn't
start sentences with Nicks you'll be
telling me but I'm not here to talk
about the first film again I'm here to
talk about the follow-up movies which
surprisingly seem to get better with
each passing one I know that sounds tree
and seeing how the first one was so bad
but with every movie more and more
improvements are made and it's
fascinating to analyze them now heads up
while I'm not gonna go into every detail
about the films particularly the fourth
one because I hasn't come out yet by the
time I'm reviewing this there are
spoilers that need to be addressed in
order for this evaluation to work so
you've been warned basically the purge
movies have gone from high school notice
me fiction to legitimately clever
commentary with each passing movie it's
almost as if the filmmakers realize the
problems with the first film and decided
let's fix them with each flick something
rarely seen in movie sequels they
usually just get worse and worse the
more they make what makes it even more
interesting as the first three films are
written and directed by the same person
James DiMaggio not only makes each film
better as they progress but he actually
goes back and retcons the issues of the
first movie in a way that doesn't
require time-traveling dreaming or
whatever the connors are going to do he
used actual clever writing making the
first movie a shitty standalone film but
an interesting POV movie when part of a
larger story was this all part of a
grand plan unlikely but it still bears
taking a look as stated before the first
film is about a family who satisfy with
the purge until they become victims of
blood hungry teens and even their own
neighbors so the husband is lost the
rest of the family survives and they
even save an innocent man who snuck into
their home for safety the lesson seemed
to be the purge is bad big shock
the following film purge anarchy takes
place the next year and follows another
of people this time though we're not
just stuck in one house we're allowed to
go outside and see how the rest of the
area they live in reacts to the purge
well there's of course psychos
everywhere there's also a resistance
group of which the guy who was hiding in
the house in the previous film is a
member of the film focus is not just
around these people surviving but also
seeing how other people used this night
to their benefit for example some folks
by people to kill on their special night
leaving the money to their family others
create giant mazes to release kidnapped
victims in order to hunt them for sport
and some like our main character Leo
want to give revenge on those who
wronged him after surviving the night
and deciding vengeance when they can
less him a man he's shot by a guy named
Big Daddy who reveals a big plot point
unfortunately the citizens aren't
killing enough so we supplemented all to
keep things balanced yep apparently the
purge doesn't work but not in the stupid
way like what the first film said it
doesn't just not work on an ethical
level it also doesn't work on an
economic level people were killing out
of grudges rather than just killing the
weak or random people meaning there was
still a lot of lower-class left so the
government secretly dispatched death
squads to increase the body count
letting the government control the
economy by just getting rid of the poor
and the helpless so it turns out there's
a lot more manipulation than we were led
to believe people were being lied to
about why the purge works technically
proving that it doesn't work it's just
the government interfering taking out
the lower social class suddenly the
first film becomes a lot more intricate
a little bit more interesting the
characters are still planned a doll but
they're blind belief that what their
government is telling them is true
suddenly seems a lot more fascinating as
long as they're not seeing it they're
less likely to question it I guess you
could argue that's always the ethical
mindset in the film but the sequel adds
a financial level to it as well so even
though these first two films do still
have problems but this is only the sixth
purge and it happens in 2023 again feel
like there be a few more steps both of
them now suddenly have relevance and
seeing how this is unavoidably a
political angle now that's where the
next film goes purge election year
centers around a senator whose family is
killed from the purge making this the
year
everyone's a campaign for president to
bring the purge to a close not
surprisingly now that these movies
reveal the government's manipulation a
lot of people are behind her and she
might possibly win naturally there's a
lot of people who don't want her to win
though so when the purge commences the
president makes a change to the rules
that now government officials are fair
game to again an obvious political move
to make them seem identifiably equal
when it's of course being used to
destroy the other side her head of
security leo from the last film does his
best protect her in light of this new
law I like how there's no one main
character through these films but there
still bleed over characters it makes the
movie seem connected in a surprisingly
non gimmicky way once again we have a
series of things going wrong and a group
of people on the run trying to survive
the night no big shock the senator gets
captured and is about to be sacrificed
by a group called the new founding
fathers of America she's saved though
and two months later is elected and as
she mentioned before intends to end the
purge so happy ending right I mean the
majority of people didn't seem to want
the purge so this should be okay well
the last few shows our main characters
listening to a report about violent
uprisings all around the country in
response to the election results it's a
grim final scene that leaves open some
interesting questions is it really over
is this just a small group of people and
not the majority who thinks this if so
how much damage can a small group do are
things only gonna get worse are they
going to get worse before they get
better if the latter how much
sacrificing is going to come from it
these questions have come a long way
since the first film that just asked the
question is the purge good or bad wow
that's diving deep and of course it's
bad these questions however are not only
more interesting in this universe but
can also draw relevance to our own
political climate but here's the
brilliant thing the political climate at
any given time no matter what party or
what candidate changing of the guard
always happens and usually with a lot of
resistance people can and have gotten
violent and sometimes it's hard to grasp
whether or not it's a loud minority or a
loud majority within the span of three
movies the purge is gone from a
laughably pretentious film too clever
satire that can mostly be utilized at
any point in time even though people
aren't literally
killing each other the dog-eat-dog world
we often live in that's exploited and
even rewarded on a daily basis can still
be seen and it's never fully gonna go
away but the fill is becoming more and
more political and judging by the poster
I'm just assuming the next one is gonna
be very heavy in that the purge movies
can actually turn into probably not a
great series but a surprisingly relevant
one granted by the time I'm reviewing
this the movie hasn't come out though
and it does have a new director so I
have no idea if it's gonna be good or
not but the directors still stayed on as
writers maybe there's still hope
if it is good this would be among the
rare group of movies that actually gets
better and better the more they make
from Mad Max - mission impossible - The
Fast and Furious movies these are films
that get better the more of them that
come out which doesn't happen often
especially if they begin from a very bad
starting point and the purge honestly
seems like one of those series it's
fascinating to see how a franchise that
easily could have pleased people by just
showing a ton of violence with only a
hair of commentary in the sequels
actually chose to not only become
smarter with every film but also try to
wreak on the problems of the previous
ones it doesn't happen often it should
be acknowledged when it does everyone
now knows the idea of the purge if you
even just say that one word this is the
first thing that pops in their head it's
like the purge Morty you've been able to
sustain world peace because you have one
night a year where you're all run around
robbing and murdering each other without
consequence that's right what it's a
wonderfully creepy idea that's work this
way into pop culture but the films are
now reflecting the possibilities of that
idea rather than just leaving it at the
simple concept it's being used to
analyze ourselves in a creepily fun and
creative way like what a lot of sci-fi
exploitation style films used to do now
don't get me wrong it's not high art if
Dylan many respects just a crazy
deranged gorefest
nevertheless it is neat to see a film
series evolve like this learning from
its mistakes and becoming more and more
relevant with each passing film I don't
know what the next movie will bring
maybe you'll be the best one yet maybe
it'll be the worst but either way the
purge doesn't look like it's leaving our
culture any time
I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember it
so you don't have to
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out in this week we are doing the
Crohn's and Colitis foundation this is a
non-profit volunteer driven organization
dedicated to finding the cures for
Crohn's disease and colitis or
inflammatory bowel disease and to
improving the quality of life of
children and adults affected by these
diseases since their founding nearly
five decades ago the foundation has
remained at the forefront of research
beyond research the foundation is
collaborating with healthcare providers
to improve IBD quality of care as well
as educating supporting and empowering
patients and their caregivers through
patient centric education and efficacy
programs today they fund cutting-edge
studies at major medical institutions
nurture investigators at the early
stages of their careers and finance
underdeveloped areas of research even
the National Institutes of Health have
condemned them for uniting the research
community and strengthening IBD research
if you look at their site in their
YouTube page you can witness all the
various ways they help spread
information and help so many people
getting closer and closer to finding a
cure click on the link and make the day
that they end this disease a reality
[Music]
you